[Musique]
oui
non
long
[Musique]
il a été suggéré de rebaptiser jusqu'à
10 de nos bases militaires légendaires
comme fort bragg en caroline du nord
fort hood au texas ford benning en
géorgie etc
ces bases monumentale et très puissantes
sont désormais partie d'un grand
patrimoine américain d'une histoire de
victoires et de liberté les etats unis
d'amérique ont formé déployer nos héros
sur ses terres sacrées et ont remporté
deux guerres mondiales
par conséquent mon administration
n'envisagera même pas de renommer ses
magnifiques et légendaire installations
militaires
notre histoire en tant que plus grande
nation du monde ne sera pas altérée
respecter nos militaires
[Musique]
ce n'est pas le peuple américain c'est
que ces noms doivent disparaître ces
noms sont des suprémacistes blancs qui
ont dit des choses terribles sur notre
pays
plus de cent ans après la seconde guerre
mondiale certains de ces noms ont été
donnés à ses bases
et si vous écoutez qui ils sont et ce
qu'ils ont dit et que vous demandez au
président d'expliquer pourquoi une base
devrait être nommé en leur honneur
il semble être la seule personne qui ne
comprend pas les termes idéologiques ou
d'un carré
[Musique]